la pandémie est vraiment derrière nous
après la longue parenthèse de la covid
la population du Québec a connu l'an
dernier la plus importante augmentation
depuis un demi-siècle 150
000 personnes de plus pour atteindre 8,8
millions de personnes la principale
raison de cette hausse le flot de
nouvelles entrées à nos frontières le
faisceleur de cette année c'est bien sûr
la migration internationale tant
permanente que temporaire les
statistiques ne mentent pas sur
l'ensemble des nouveaux québécois
69000 sont des immigrants permanents et
87000 des résidents non permanents
soient plus de 95% de la hausse de
population enregistré cette année on n'a
pas connu des taux de croissance aussi
importants au Québec depuis l'époque où
l'essentiel de la croissance était dû à
très très grande fécondité des familles
québécoises mais tout est relatif malgré
donner record toutes les autres
provinces ont accueilli
proportionnellement presque deux fois
plus des migrants que nous en
conséquence le poids démographique des
autres provinces continuent d'augmenter
alors que celui du Québec diminue
en 76 le Québec représentait 27% de la
population canadienne en 2023 tout juste
22% sur le plan de la natalité les
naissances au Québec sont en baisse de
5%, les femmes ont un généralement et
d'enfants et la plupart au début de la
trentaine une tendance qui n'est pas
nouvelle les préoccupations
environnementales sont de plus en plus
cités c'est difficile de savoir à quel
point ça peut faire un choix dans la
décision d'avoir un enfant ou pas mais
bien sûr l'incertitude économique a
toujours été lié à au rapport du projet
de famille à noter également l'espérance
de vie des Québécois a retrouvé son
seuil prépondément soit 84 ans pour les
femmes et 80 pour les hommes ce qui en
fait toujours l'une des plus élevées au
monde ici normand Grondin Radio-Canada
Montréal